you
[Music]
this morning on the dish he worked with
some of the country's top chefs and then
became one himself
Jonathan Benna was raised in Connecticut
farm country where family dinners
included his grandmother's eggplant
parmesan
made with eggplant right out of his
garden after training at the Culinary
Institute of America he learned from the
best in the business including Daniel
Boulud Tom Colicchio and Thomas Keller
and it was Keller who had him open his
new flagship per se
later he ran the kitchen of the
acclaimed Lincoln restaurant a now he's
taken over at New York's Evelyn hotel
opening Leonelli taberna Leonelli focus
area and his namesake Ben Oh chef
Jonathan Ben oh good morning welcome to
the dish morning thank you tell us about
this table because it looks terrific
well the table represents three of the
concepts that we have in the Evelyn
hotel on 27th Street
first is the slowly Attell which is a
traditional Italian pastry from Naples
and then we move into some of the dishes
that represent the Taverna roasted
mushrooms eggplant parmesan we do
large-format dinners in taberna leg of
lamb is one of the offerings and then
last is a dish that represents our fine
dining restaurant bento which is a very
seasonal spring ravioli it is so good
very happy as we toast you and say
Cheers
what are we doing so this is a spritz
from Rome that features blood orange
juice beautiful Cheers
you know we mentioned growing up you had
these big family dinners that seems
obvious as to why you'd be attracted to
food but it was also your father and
your uncle you had a lot of influences
on you yeah my my dad was very good at
cooking eggs breakfast for dinner was a
special my uncle is actually a very good
baker so we grew up with we grew up with
his pies what was it about those dinners
and that family cooking that that just
intrigued you well I was lucky enough to
grow up at a at a time and a place where
you know the family came together on
Sunday afternoon yeah sadly I think
we're we're losing that a little bit
okay one of your early jobs was was was
at the Hard Rock Cafe in Hawaii I know
yeah when I got out of high school I
wasn't sure what I wanted to do yeah so
I moved to Hawaii and that was that was
my first job was a the line you were on
the line yeah I started I started making
salads there that was a good place but
you were washing dishes somewhere though
I love that story yeah that was my that
was my very first job in Connecticut I
was a dishwasher so you go to the CIA
the Culinary Institute of America
and you decide hey I'm bailing the East
Coast I'm going to the west coast what
went into that decision well at that
time you know this was 1993 San
Francisco was really exploding and there
was a there was a restaurant there
called aqua that I got to shortly after
it opened it was a seafood focused
restaurant michael Mina's restaurant and
it was one of the at that time one of
the hottest restaurants in the city one
of the hottest restaurants in the
country your mentors it's like a
murderer yeah Colicchio Keller blue I
mean they're killers that's for sure I
mean it's like that's that's a heck of a
way to come into the industry yeah I was
I was very lucky I made great choices
and work for some really talented people
over the years
yeah they obviously had such an
influence on you you now mentors you're
in charge of your restaurants is there a
philosophy that you took from them or
one that you have now when you look to
mentoring well you know young just as I
as a young person sought out chef Keller
and chef Beaulieu and chef Colicchio to
learn now I'm in a position where you
know young people come to work with us
learn the craft of cooking any pressure
having your name on a restaurant now
just a little bit and speaking of your
name I'm gonna have you sign the dish if
you could have this meal with anyone
past or present who would it be you know
I'd probably I'd probably choose my mom
she was she passed away several years
ago and I didn't have an opportunity to
share
this with her although she did he did
many of the restaurants that I worked
with over the years no doubt she would
enjoy be very proud of benefit or thank
you chef Jonathan Ben Owen for more on
chef Ben o and the dish you can head to
our website at CBS this morning calm